hello I'm gonna style your credit guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know I found myself searching for
something deeper and more meaningful in
life so I decided to turn to the master
of enlightenment himself the dalai lama
i found a video where he talks about how
compassion is not a sign of weakness and
the responsibility one has banking their
actions with the undeniable truth so
moved by these incredible words i was a
little shocked to find that only 2,000
people actually view this video really
the worldly known teacher of buddhism
only has a little over two thousand hits
well after that i decided i need
something a little bit more lighthearted
so i put on this dumb
it was a little shocked to find that not
only did have over 2,000 hits but it had
well this amount and that's for the five
hour version of this video why do we
love stupid I don't mean the fads that
are popular for a short amount of time
I mean legitimately timeless hilarious
stupid I'm talking about the ren and
stimpy the dumb and dumber x' the Monty
Python's Flying Circus --is those
ridiculous YouTube videos that make no
sense but for some reason still get a
big laugh out of you every time what is
it that can make things we know are
idiotic good like we know this is stupid
and doesn't make us giggle I feel like a
duck-billed platypus hey but we also
know that this is stupid that for some
reason makes us laugh our asses off
well you're the most annoying sound in
the world
these things don't take as much effort
and focus as a band Costello's brilliant
writing or buster Keaton's unbelievable
stunts it's just stupid so why are we so
lenient to certain stupid routines and
yet so harsh on others why do we laugh
so hard at something a two-year-old
would laugh just as hard at well let's
first understand why the hell we laugh
to begin with in my opinion I think it's
a defense mechanism I as well as make
comedians before have said that all
comedy is based on misery well the
reason for that is if we did have comedy
all we would do is sit around and feel
bad about the stuff happening around us
comedy helps us confront the bad things
in front of us and cope with it I'm sure
a lot of people in one way or another
were injured in a similar way the Three
Stooges were in many of their shorts
hell Houdini died by a blow to the
stomach but we don't think the Stooges
are going too far when they punch one
another in the stomach why because it's
saying that suffering is a part of life
and by laughing at it you acknowledge
that though painful it's all part of the
journey it's a way to adjust to the bad
things happening around us and move on
okay fair enough but how does something
like this
connect to misery
well maybe not misery of the character
you're watching but certainly a jolt to
your expectations we've all seen
screamers before those videos that make
you think it's one thing and then
suddenly a cheap scare pops up and we've
all gone through them and they've been
done a million times and we're really
sick of it but in minute the first time
you ever saw one
you felt a burst of life in you this
comes from an instinct to keep you on
your guard like an animal does to
prepare for danger but when you find out
it's not dangerous you have yourself a
good laugh as well the reasons people
like going to scary movies stupid humor
is kind of the same way well not every
silly joke needs to rely on scaring you
into laughter it still has to rely on
playing with your expectations that is
relying on the unexpected and that rush
of trying to get a handle on what's
going to happen but never fully getting
that grasp can be exciting fun and of
course hilarious in a show like Monty
Python's Flying Circus they thrive on
the unexpected even to a point of
insulting your sense of humor how long
can this get keep using the word spam
just when you think something in them
has to know they need to stop they just
keep going
[Music]
again playing with the expectation of
just when you think something is going
to cease it surprises you and continues
making even the repeat of one word
suddenly funny again gosh my mistake
Andy Kaufman made a living playing with
both your expectations and your patience
he wants did a stand-up where all he did
was eat a bowl of ice cream
people were so confused and so caught
off guard that they couldn't help but
laugh at it I'd like to do for you right
now
he bit which got me thrown out of the
improv
I haven't done it since summer although
I have tried it a few times and it never
has worked I'd like to do it for you
tonight but this isn't just blind
randomness there is technique to it a
part of this works because of its
buildup people think it's gonna be
something shocking and risque when
really it's just a huge waste of time so
don't be confused there is certainly
method to the madness the YouTube video
Batman eating a hot dog has over 4
million views how it's just Batman
eating a hot dog well that's because
people can't believe that someone went
to all the effort to animate very well
animate by the way one of America's
greatest superheroes doing nothing but
eating a hotdog but now if it was just a
line drawing or a still of Batman doing
that it wouldn't be as funny the
animator knew it still had to feel like
Batman if it didn't the joke wouldn't
work so he made it intense dark and
over-the-top and epic all just for the
simple task of eating process
so why does something stupid like that
get so much laughter and yet something
like the starving games becomes
universally hated one of the reasons for
that is that something like the starving
games doesn't take any risks you know
the kind of jokes they're going to do
because you've seen them a million times
now Brooks did it the Zucker brothers
did it SNL did it we're all used to this
kind of formula I think you can safely
say that Batman eating a hotdog has not
been done before as far as we know that
has never existed but that does bring up
one of the biggest problems with stupid
humor when it becomes predictable as
much as I love Monty Python's Flying
Circus if you watch it long enough you
start to realize a bit of a pattern you
watch somebody being crazy you think the
normal person is going to react normally
but it turns out the normal person is
just as crazy as the crazy person
pruning necessary I'd still like the
operation please do an operation early
if you'll come on a camping holiday with
me don't get me wrong there's other
jokes too and once that break the mold
but that seemed to be the one that
popped up the most that kind of joke
relies on being unexpected but when it's
done a few times you start to catch on
the fact is it's difficult to
continually be unexpected because if you
keep doing things are unexpected they
suddenly become expected I think that's
why we laugh so hard when we see
something that is so strange
and is so unusual because truth be told
it is difficult to be silly and goofy
while also being funny not everybody has
it and it's not always the easiest to
obtain it's an instinct that relies not
only on what most people are expecting
but what most people have already seen
starving games is predictable and tired
where nobody could predict that when he
met held aloft his magic sword he would
say one
my live and my life and stay committed
to it throughout the entire song
something that was so unpredictable and
so out of left field that people are
coming back to it time after time to
make it more popular now the other
all-knowing truth that a lot of people
talk about with comedy aside from it all
being about misery is that it's all
subjective maybe none of this stupid
stuff got a giggle out of you maybe you
do just look at and say that's really
dumb why is everybody else laughing at
this but I'm willing to bet that there's
something out there that you know is
stupid and yet you still can't help but
howl with laughter at something you
can't explain you can't figure out but
it just makes you laugh comedy isn't an
exact science but there certainly are
things that a huge amount of people will
find joy in and whether it be
intelligent or stupid the one thing we
can take from both of them is that they
both take effort yes everyone can get
lucky with one stupid routine here or
there or one silly moment that happened
by accident and resulted in 15 minutes
of fame but for something to continue to
be funny and keep people coming back
that takes a great deal of talent some
rely on hours of research others rely on
seconds of instinct but both have an art
that requires a lot of dedication and a
ton of trial and error but given all the
variations of people out there as well
as millions of different senses of humor
nobody's going to hit the majority all
the time so even something as silly as
this is doing something that connects
with millions of people's senses of
humor whether they realize it or not so
the next time you say something is so
stupid or so dumb just keep telling
yourself if it's making you laugh harder
than anything else has that day it just
might be a little smarter than you think
it is
now is time for K Islander stars your
credit guy remembered because
[Music]